hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 15 video
subheading crazy Rick episode there's so
much awesome stuff to guess who so I'll
just remind everyone that a new round of
the giveaway starts now all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video and careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet starting with top five moments
number five nine-inch Walking Dead nails
technically the band is broken up but I
love the mix the Deanna's family was
listening to at the beginning of the
episode such a great way to open the
episode I think I mentioned it in
previous videos but The Walking Dead
tries to mix things up with the way they
shoot their intros like sometimes
they'll be really cinematic sometimes
they'll use really interesting music I
think my second favorite music episode
of Walking Dead our music intro was the
Bob Stokey intro from season four both
very sad ways to open the episode but I
felt like the Bob Stokey one was a
little more melancholy the Trent Reznor
music is just to get you amped up which
is why they intercut with Carol's oven
heating up the oven of Alexandria is
heating up they also had the Carl eated
cooking timer thing too I just love the
way cooking is a metaphor for this
season finale
even though Deanna seems super pissed
that she left the casserole on the
doorstep it still seems like she's
coming from a place of sanity like she
hasn't completely lost it yet she's a
politician so she knows how it goes on
to number four Deanna in rick argue
about what to do with pete this is a
really good example of balancing forces
in the episode so like they don't want
you to think that any one character is
more right than the other rick's
perspective is valid Deanna's is too she
doesn't want to kill anyone
but he doesn't want to let the abuse
continued really the thing that sells it
for me is when rick tells Jesse later
inside here is the same as out there it
depends on whether or not you believe
him when he says that which side you
come down on if you agree that the rules
of the outside world should be the same
as the rules inside Alexandria then then
you're in Rick's camp ultimately I think
most people will come down on Rick's
side letting wounds fester like Pete
being a giant wound will only cause
Alexandria to rot from the inside it's
not gonna get better people will still
die no matter what whether they die at
the hands of abuse or at the barrel of
Rick's revolver on to number three
sasha goes crazy I don't mean that she's
literally going crazy I just mean that
she's going a little bit nuts the sugar
nuts all over
Walker's Michonne and Rosita went a
little nuts too I think they took the
opportunity out with Sasha in the woods
to let off some steam they want you to
think Sasha's going nuts but really she
hasn't done anything that doesn't need
to be done someone should be taking care
of all those walkers so why not her
she's actually doing them a service and
even though she took down Rick at the
end of the episode I still think that
Michonne is going back and forth in her
head about the way she wants to live her
life like if she wants to adopt these
Alexandria's way of life or if she wants
to continue to be that person with the
katana I just I love that flashback
scene to her that was her debut in
season 3 that was the first time she
ever appeared or technically it was the
season 2 finale that's the mode that
sasha is in right now and I feel like
Michonne is gonna take her katana off
the wall in the finale at some point
something really important to remember -
sasha is hanging up in the tower she
kind of saw there was a commotion going
on with Rick's fight at the end but she
used the opportunity to just pick off a
bunch of walkers at the wall nickolas
the one that actually had stolen Rick's
gun the one that hitted in the coffee
can stole it he heard the gunshots at
the wall they didn't address that but
I'm wondering if Nikolas is going to
overlap with Sasha in the Tower
if anyone were gonna take him down I
would want Sasha to be the one to do it
moving on to number two Daryl Aaron
uncover more signs of the Wolves they
waited till the end of the episode to
explain it but they've been finding dead
Walker's everywhere all over the place
then they found a bunch that were
chopped up into bits then they found the
woman that was tied to the tree and if
it wasn't totally clear from the way
they said it she was alive when she was
tied up to that tree meaning that these
quote-unquote
wolves are sick as [ __ ] if you remember
back to the episode where Tyreese died
there was that sign that said wolves not
far I think I've said it in a couple of
my previous videos but I think they're
just stand-ins for the scavengers from
the comics just a terrible group of
people in and around the DC area not to
be confused with negan and the Savior's
totally different group I know that
doesn't answer the question as to where
Morgan is because I know a lot of people
were hoping that Daryl would run into
Morgan he could still show up in the
finale there's still a lot of questions
about what's going on with Morgan's
storyline and how it's gonna tie back in
with the survivors so just open up a
bookmark and Chrome for wolves and
Morgan and my number one WTF moment of
course Rick versus porchdick I think we
were all expecting this to happen so
it's not a huge surprise it's from the
comics I think the way they're doing it
the show is just a little bit different
there drawing it out just a little bit
more but I think we all expect it to go
down the same way it's like Alexandria
is Thunderdome two men enter one man
leave all I could think about when they
were going at it when they were actually
fighting was Peter Griffin fighting the
giant chicken on Family Guy in all
seriousness though they want you to
question as to who's gonna win that
fight like they didn't want it to be an
easy win for Ric Pizza big guy and even
though he's day drunk it's gonna take a
lot for Ric to take him down with his
fist normally he just shoot him but I
think because they were in that
community
Ric was hesitant to just draw his gun
and fire that seemed right after he
talked to Jesse the first time was him
just looking at all the kids people
sitting around you think that he was
formulating a plan but honestly I don't
think that he has much of a plan in his
head he's just like I'm gonna deal with
this the way I deal with everything the
problem is is they're in Alexandria and
there's a giant group of people living
there that have no idea what's going on
and aren't used to his way of doing
things it was so much fun watching Rick
try to explain himself to Jesse he's so
inarticulate he just he couldn't come
out and say I really care about you
that's his Neanderthal way of
communicating to her that he really
cares about her love in the time of
Apocalypse I haven't heard anything
about Jesse's surviving to season six
hopefully she makes it I mean I would
like to see something develop between
those two characters but first porchdick
has to be removed from the equation so
here's my big question for you guys how
do you think they're going to resolve
this Rick porch dick situation it seems
like what they're suggesting from the
teaser for the next episode that Rick
will end up killing Pete but somehow the
Wolves storyline will intersect with
that so it won't just be Rick versus
Pete it'll be Rick versus Pete in the
context of this greater threat of the
wolves and a giant army of walkers that
seem to be massing at the gates more and
more it's kind of like the prison round
two only this time Rick's group is the
invading force I've seen a lot of you
guys comments on previous videos from
this season about you know is Rick the
villain this time around or not has he
turned into Shane has he turned into the
governor I don't think that he has but I
think they definitely want you to wonder
because anybody who just stumbled upon
this episode and had no idea who Rick is
and watched that scene at the end they
would think that Rick is crazy they're
like oh my god what is wrong with this
guy it isn't until you look at the
broader context that you start to
sympathize with Rick more
because look at all the things he's been
through had they dealt with the governor
this same way like right away Woodbury
probably wouldn't have gone down the
same way all those people probably
wouldn't have died
same thing goes for the prison if you
want to make the rick shan comparison
then think about it this way
shane was much quicker i think much much
quicker than rick to sacrifice members
of the group i think rick still thinks
about it like it's still a measure of
last resort but he won't hesitate once
he's decided that someone needs to you
know go they've changed a few things
from the comics if you have read along
in the comics just use spoiler tags it's
a little more clear-cut which decision
has to be made like what rick has to do
and the circumstances on the show that
are keeping pete alive aren't quite the
same in the comics he's not quite as
necessary to the people of alexandria as
he is on the show so don't forget next
week's episode is the finale be sure to
subscribe to get my video i'll be doing
a double giveaway and i'll be doing some
bonus videos that to the fact i'll still
do a Q&A but also do some extra bonus
videos after the finale feel free to
leave any requests but now we're like
we're like in a territory where we can
talk about season six especially after
the finale we can start speculating on
when negan's gonna show up what's gonna
happen with the next big group of
villains what they're gonna do inside
alexandria once they deal with porchdick
and i know i didn't mention in my top
five moments but we all have to give
Carl a giant high-five forgetting a
little play in the woods
Carl's now one of the most eligible
bachelors inside of the safe zone under
the age of 18 so while you guys wait for
me to post The Walking Dead Q&A tomorrow
you can click here for my latest Game of
Thrones Season 5 video I just made a
Daenerys video and you can click here
for all my other Walking Dead Season 5
videos thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you